scp-999 versus scp-106  how would the cuddliest of all scps fare  in a battle with the foundation's most  diabolical geriatric monster our theory  is that 999 with his unstoppable good  vibe powers could be the only one to  reform this gloopy wall walking maniac  he might help 106 overcome his desire to  do evil and begin to change him back  into the sweet old man he was always  meant to be instead of killing people  he'd take up fishing instead of handfuls  of human teeth he'd have a pocket full  of caramels instead of torturing you  forever he'd just playfully pinch your  cheek okay maybe the turnaround wouldn't  be that miraculous but we can dream  right